- Hey guys, my name is Heinrich.
Welcome back to my
channel "Firm Learning",
and to another coffee break with me.
It is actually the first coffee
that I was drinking today.
This morning I worked a lot in PowerPoint
on creating different types
of PowerPoint presentations
for the work that I'm currently doing,
and this just reminded me
of the time in consulting
where I literally created
thousands of PowerPoint pages
over a time span of about six years.
I know that this can actually
be quite challenging.
It is quite a learning
development that you do
as a junior business
analyst joining consulting,
just learning the tools of PowerPoint
until you're a professional
of several years
and then really do these slides well.
There's much more to it than it seems.
Creating good and compelling
PowerPoint presentations
is not easy at all,
it's really a craft that
you learn over time.
And even after one or
two years in consulting,
you will still not be
there where you need to be
to really have these things
at a professional level
where they need to be in the end.
For that, I at some point a
few years ago created a course,
it's called, "A Course on Slide Writing",
on creating PowerPoint presentations
as top consulting firms do.
And one of the topics that
I cover in this course
is action titles.
Action titles is an important part
of every good professional
PowerPoint page.
It's the title that appears
in the very top of the page.
And in this video, I would
like to give you an insight
into how these action titles
are supposed to be written,
are supposed to be crafted.
And if you now say, "Who
cares about the title,
"this is unimportant,"
you're completely wrong.
I can tell you, those action
titles are a crucial part
of every PowerPoint presentation.
So let me show you what's all about it
and how to write a good and
compelling action title.
This section is all about action titles.
You already learned about action titles
in the introductory section on storylines,
but I think it is
important that you really
understand this concept in detail,
because writing good action titles
is actually really important,
and very crucial and key
to create a winning and
successful storyline.
So let's dive into a bit more detail.
And what I have here is an
attempt of a definition.
So this is my own very
personal definition.
Please don't cite me on that.
But I hope this helps you understand this
a bit better what it is.
So let me just read it out to you.
Action titles are headers
of a slide presentation
that summarize the content of the slide
by formulating a complete sentence.
So, just to go in it point by
point what exactly that means.
Action titles are the
headers of a presentation.
So, the header would
be something like this.
Here again, you see
that this is formulated
in the style of an action title.
And then second, of a slide presentation.
So yes, we are talking
about slide presentations
like in PowerPoint or other programs.
So this is where action titles are used.
And they're supposed to
summarize the content.
Here again, here's the definition,
and then in the title, you always try
to really get the gist of
what the page is showing.
If you remember at the
beginning, there was the slide
with the horizontal
and the vertical logic.
So, in order for you to
really write a winning logic,
you need to make sure
that the action titles
actually really represent
what the reader is seeing on the page.
And then finally, they are written
by formulating a complete sentence.
So if you look at these
titles, a title like that,
you can see that it's
really a complete sentence,
so they had to create a clear storyline
within a presentation.
It is not just the title
of a couple of words.
You see these people
making quite often that,
for instance on a slide like that,
somebody would only write
action title definition
or something like that.
And the problem with that is that,
if you create the headers of your page
or of your slide like that,
it's not really possible
to just skip through all the
pages and get the key message.
Because in most cases the titles,
if you formulate them that way,
won't really be speaking for themselves.
It's usually then always
necessary to really read the page
in order to get the key
message out of the page.
But with action titles, we
want to enable exactly that,
so that the page itself
isn't that important anymore.
The key message is already
in the action title.
And now I would like to
introduce a very familiar concept
that can be helpful when
formulating action titles.
So, if you struggle to come
up with the good action title,
the reason for that
could be that your page
actually lacks something
that is called a "So what?"
So, what do we mean when we
talk about the "So what?"
So, imagine you look at the slide,
and there could be all kinds
of information on the slide.
Maybe you did a fancy analysis,
you see different kinds
of charts and so on,
and maybe that's interesting.
But sometimes you will find yourself
asking the question, so what?
So why does it matter
what I see on the slide?
What is the implication for my business,
for the project that I'm working on?
That is depicted here on this slide.
And this is actually what
many people do wrong.
They create some kind of analysis,
and maybe it's fancy and
maybe it's interesting,
but they lack to really put out there
what the implication of that is.
Or you could say they do not really show
what the "So what" of the page is.
So, whenever you struggle and wonder,
do I really need this page,
or ask yourself what a
good action title would be,
maybe start with asking yourself,
so what, why do I need this page?
So, what is the message?
And if you cannot really
come up with a good so what,
then probably this page
lacks a strong key message,
and then you would either, usually,
need to take this page out,
or you would need to
restructure it, to recreate it,
for you to enable it
to have a key message.
So, if you can't come
up with an action title,
ask yourself critically if
this so what is actually there.
What I will do now is, I
will give you an exercise
which I hope will help you to really
distinguish good from bad action titles,
and you will see that in the next section.
In this section, I'm
doing an exercise with you
that will hopefully
help you to distinguish
good action titles from bad,
or maybe not so good action titles.
And what you see here is a page,
and I deleted the action
title from the page.
I mean, it's not important
that you understand
all the nitty-gritty details,
but just to quickly give you the summary.
You see here kind of two regions,
North America the first column here,
and the second column Asia Pacific,
and then there is some
kind of quantification
of the EBIT potential.
So EBIT is kind of a term for the profit,
the profit of a company.
So here's basically a profit potential
if the company would decide
to enter these regions,
and we showed that here.
And so, the first question that
I would like to ask you is,
what would be a good
action title to that page?
So, please now pause the video
and take whatever time you need
to come up with a suggestion,
and then afterwards we will
discuss this suggestion.
So stop the video now,
and then let's resume in a few seconds.
Okay, now you have a suggestion,
and maybe even write it
down if that helps you.
Because this way, you cannot
really cheat yourself.
And what we will do
now is, we will go over
a couple of other suggestions
that I prepared for you.
And after each one we can ask ourselves,
is this a good action title or not?
And here again, feel
free to pause the video
after every action title suggestion
that I will blend in now.
And before then I tell you
what I think, ask yourself
is this a good action title or not?
Let's begin with the first suggestion,
derived potentials for an expansion.
So would this be a good
action title to this page?
And again, pause the video
if you need a second to think about it.
And so here, I would argue no,
this is not a good action title. Why not?
Because actually, it doesn't
really fit in the definition.
And why not? Because basically,
it's not a full sentence.
It doesn't really give you
the key message of this page in the title.
It just tells you that
this is a title that has
something to do with derived
potentials for an expansion,
but it doesn't really tell
you what the potential is.
So is this something good or bad,
is the potential positive or negative?
So basically, to really
get the message out of it,
you would really have to read the page.
Otherwise, it's not possible.
And this is the opposite
of what an action title
is supposed to do.
So this is the second example.
Let me read it out to you.
Expansion to new geographies
creates a positive EBIT potential.
Once again, pause the video if you like.
So, is this a good action title or not?
And here, I would argue
that it's too generic.
So it's a bit better than
the first section title,
because this actually is a full sentence,
and it really conveys a message.
It says to you that there
is a positive EBIT potential
in tapping these new geographies,
but it's still too generic.
You can get much more detailed than that,
and we will see this in future examples.
So here, another new
suggestion for an action title.
Again, pause the video.
Is this a good action title or not?
Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
creates a positive EBIT potential.
And what you see here, is that this is now
much more concrete than the
first one and the second one,
because now it talks
about the specific regions
that this page is looking into.
So yes, now we're really getting closer
to a good result, to a good action title.
And nevertheless, I would argue
that you can do better than that.
Because when possible,
it's always a good idea
to really quantify the
things that you analyzed.
And now, this is what the
next example is all about.
And here again, expansion to
North America and Asia Pacific
creates a positive EBIT
potential of 22 euro million.
So, I mean what's wrong with that?
So this is, I would
say, already very good.
And if you catch that, so 22 million
would be the sum of the 12
million and the 10 million here.
Or, it says also here the 22 million.
The only thing that I would
criticize with this title
is that it is a bit too wordy.
You can formulate the very
same message with fewer words,
and this is usually always
advantageous, because then
the reader doesn't have
to go into too much detail
to really get the key message out of it.
So, one final suggestion.
Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
with 22 euro million EBIT potential.
And I would argue yes, this
is a good action title.
It summarizes the key message of the page.
It is pretty concise and short.
It doesn't use too much words
to put this message across.
So I think this would
be a feasible option.
And of course, in the end,
I think it's important
to emphasize that of
course, there's nothing like
the mathematically correct
perfect action title.
There are many feasible options,
but probably some action
titles are better than others.
And I would just really
encourage you to think about
whether your action title
is as good as it could be,
and I hope that this example
gives you some food for thought
in order to get to that conclusion.
So just in the end, what
I would like you to do is,
again here in the Q&A
section of this course
that appears in the bottom of the page
if you hover here with the mouse,
I think it says "Browse Q&A", just enter
maybe an alternative solution
that you came up with,
and then you have the
opportunity to also check out
what other classmates
of yours came up with,
and then hopefully you can also learn
from these other solutions
that other people created.
So guys, I hope you enjoyed this course
on creating good and
compelling action titles.
Maybe you even had a coffee just as I had,
over time while watching this.
And if you would like to
learn more on how to create
these professional
consulting-style looking
PowerPoint slides, more
than just the action title,
check out the description below.
There is a link to my
course where you have
basically a full
back-to-back course lecture
on how to create presentations
like consulting firms,
like for instance, BGG or Bain will do.
Thank you, hope you enjoy it.
If you haven't subscribed yet
to this channel, please do,
that would mean the world to me.
Thank you, and have a good day.